dear pierre gattas and marcos baira
distinguished guests and dear friends
i'm so sorry i cannot welcome you to the
berlimo today
i saw some of you just a couple of weeks
ago and i saw others in evian at the end
of the summer
and our meetings are always a great
source of ideas and inspiration
i know that you have a very dense
program with my colleagues and my team
today
so i won't keep you too long
i would just like to introduce three
topics
that i am sure will feature prominently
in today's meetings
so
first a renewed focus on international
trade and connectivity is necessary
in the coming weeks we will present our
new connectivity strategy called global
gateway europe
we want to step up our investment in
different kinds of infrastructure
to connect the world
including for example digital
connections ranging from submarine
cables
to cloud infrastructure
but also energy connections such as new
hydrogen market with the african
continent
and in each of these fields
we will work to ensure
that european industry can operate
on an equal footing with foreign
competitors
think about this
18 of jobs in the european union are
linked to our
exports so global gateway europe is
immensely important for our recovery
but it goes much further
europe is offering transparency
and good governance to our partners
my second point
is a crucial topic
we need to focus on value chains
we all by now know well
that the european union is critically
dependent
on imports from threat countries
we don't want our production lines to be
slowed down by global shortages
and foreign bottlenecks
we want to work with you
to strengthen europe's resilience
the industry's feedback will be
essential
to assess
and to address these dependencies
on our side
we will continue to seek partnerships
and alliances with the private sector
this is the logic of our new industrial
alliances
and it is also the logic of the european
ships act
and we are glad to see that a giant like
intel
has just announced
an investment of up to 95 billion
dollars in european chip making
facilities
so together we can create a
state-of-the-art european ship ecosystem
that is at the same time
open to the world
and competitive on global markets
and my third point
i know that the current rise of energy
prices
is very high on your gender and i can
assure you it's high on our agenda as
well
the whole world is affected
irrespective of countries energy
and climate policies or electricity
market design
and we have to draw lessons from this
experience
and let me name three
my first is we are too dependent on gas
ninety percent of the gas we use is
imported and that is not sustainable
we need to discuss a european strategic
reserve
and we need to discuss the possibility
of common procurement
my second point is
we need to make our energy system more
resilient to price and supply shocks
thus investing in renewables is the
obvious policy choice
they are increasingly cheaper in
production
their production prices and costs have
decreased over the last years
and renewables are homegrown
alongside this
we need stable sources
nuclear
and during the transition
natural gas
and my third point
is that in the short term we need to
support those affected most by the
energy price shocks
and that is vulnerable consumers
and heavily exposed businesses
measures can be taken very swiftly
eu rules allow relief through state aid
they allow targeted support to consumers
and of course to cut energy taxes or
reduce levees on energy bills
but the long-term solution lies in the
european green deal
we must keep on investing in renewable
clean energy
and in europe's competitiveness on the
green markets of tomorrow
and this is exactly what we are doing
with next generation you our recovery
plan
in the national plans submitted so far
36 billion euros will be spent for clean
energy
i'm speaking of green hydrogen for
example or offshore and onshore wind
farms
or new industrial sites using renewable
energy
partnerships with the business sectors
are vital to this
and together
we will make europe more competitive and
resilient to price shocks
europe is stronger when governments and
businesses join forces towards common
goals
so thank you very much for listening to
me and giving me your attention
and let me wish you a very fruitful day
at the european commission